[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir les législatives mannes
financières pour les partis politiques
avec plus de 300 députés en 2017 la
république en marche a touché plus de
100 millions d'euros sur la législature
et si c'était l'un des enjeux principaux
pour beaucoup de formations à l'heure où
le ps ait l'air et le rn sont en
difficultés financières on va faire le
point sur toutes les règles en vigueur
pour déclencher les financements publics
sont elles adaptées faut-il tout changé
législatives un pactole pour cinq ans de
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
la no1 vie et notre grand témoin et
journaliste éditorialiste au monde
ancien correspondant à washington
jérusalem ou encore terran il analyse
dans son dernier essai la lente agonie
des démocraties libérales à face à
l'irrésistible ascension de lachine ça
s'appelle un autre monde l'ère des
dictateurs c'est aux éditions perrin
alan trash on est avec nous et se soit
enfin nous retrouverons nova franchi
pour leur parti pris le carnet de
campagne dès l'amont d'un gab a comme
chaque soir sur les législatives la
chronique de thibaut enoch hier
aujourd'hui demain sur les sommets de la
terre et l'oeil sur le monde numérique
de delphine sabattier voilà pour menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs les campagnes
électorales ce sont aussi des affaires
de gros sous alors à dix jours du
premier tour des législatives
lcp va tout vous expliquer des règles en
vigueur et des stratégies des partis
politiques pour financer leur formation
à la faveur de cette élection bonsoir
anne charlotte bezina bonsoir ravis de
vous accueillir sur ce plateau vous êtes
constitutionnaliste maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université de rouen bonsoir richard
wehrli soit mairie les ires de vous
retrouver visage familier de cette
émission dans laquelle vous êtes un
excellent chroniqueur correspondant par
ailleurs france europe pour le quotidien
suisse blick bonsoir maître louis le
foyer de costil bienvenue à vous vous
êtes avocat en droit public vous
connaissez bien les lois électorales qui
nous amène parfois des contentieux
électoraux on en parlera sûrement et
puis un politique sur ce plateau qui va
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant il est sénateur socialiste il
est donc pas candidat totalement libres
de parole il s'appelle rachid de thé mal
sénateur socialiste du val d'oise et qui
n'est pas favorable et à la nuque baisse
de jean-luc mélenchon autant dire qu'on
a pas mal de questions à lui à lui poser
parce que tout est lié les alliances
mais aussi les financements vous allez
nous expliquer tout ça on a besoin de
votre éclairage une fois n'est pas
coutume c'est valérie bouchard qui s'y
colle ce soir si j'ai bien compris la
politique c'est aussi une histoire
d'argent
[Musique]
valérie bonsoir si j'ai bien compris on
a beaucoup parlé des législatives dans
cette émission les stratégies les
projets le pouvoir d'achat qui écrase
tout ce soir on parle gros sous
évidemment myriam et ça rigole pas un
les déplacement en minibus les locations
de chaises pliables et cacahuètes le
petit verre de cidre après les réunions
publiques les affiches les tracts et
bien tout ça ça coûte des sous et ses
dépenses comme pour la présidentielle
elles sont évidemment encadrée alors
comment ça marche précisément réelle
alors premiers éléments les candidats
aux élections législatives ne peuvent
pas piocher dans leur porte-monnaie
interdiction d'utiliser ses comptes
personnels pour financer leur campagne
il faut ouvrir un compte spécifique
détenus par un mandataire financier il
est nommé par le candidat et il doit
lister tous les frais c'est clair c'est
simple c'est transparent quelles sont
les sources financières autorisé pour
payer leurs campagnes myriam les
candidats aux législatives peuvent
accepter un les dons des personnes
physiques vous moi en tant que personne
on peut donner jusqu'à 4600 euros à un
candidat alors attention hein par chèque
ou virement bancaire à partir de 150
euros les partis politiques aussi
peuvent aider et soutenir leur candidat
mais il est strictement interdit de
donner de l'argent un candidat si vous
représentez une personne morale comme
une entreprise un pays étranger un
syndicat ou une association
j'imagine que toutes ces dépenses elles
sont pas illimitées non vous imaginez
bien myriam un candidat aux élections
législatives ne peut pas dépenser plus
de 38000 euros auxquels s'ajoutent 15
centimes par habitant de la
circonscription alors ça c'est pour la
campagne sur le terrain des candidats
après la campagne et il ya le vote est
l'enjeu est majeur pour les geste hâtif
parce que c'est surtout ces élections
qui financent les partis politiques en
france et oui mais rien peu de gens le
savent mais grâce à nous ce soir grâce à
cvr ils vont tous comprendre le
financement des partis politiques
français dépend d'une aide publique
basée sur les élections aient
législatives c'est très simple les
partis politiques vivent grâce aux
cotisations de leurs adhérents ok ça
c'est compris mais aussi et surtout
grâce à une aide publique une aide de
l'état une dotation qui se calcule en
fonction des résultats aux élections
législatives et cette aide publique elle
est distribuée en deux parties la
première partie environ 32 millions
d'euros et distribue en fonction des
résultats du premier tour pour y avoir
droit un parti doit présenter au moins
cinquante candidats et ses 50 ans ida
doivent doivent obtenir au moins 1% des
voix au premier tour si c'est le cas les
parties concernées se partagent alors
les 32 millions proportionnellement
attention si la parité femmes hommes
n'est pas respectée dans les candidats
alors ils viennent il y aura une retenue
sur la somme dû on ferme la parenthèse
si on compte bien au moins cinquante
candidats sur les 577 circonscriptions
qui ont tous remporté minimum 1 % des
voix alors les parties pourront toucher
la seconde part de l'aide publique à peu
près 30 4 millions d'euros à se partager
tout simplement en fonction du nombre de
parlementaires élus députés et sénateurs
confondues plus on a des lui qui sera
attaché un parti plus on touche une part
importante des 34 millions d'euros elmer
ces conditions on comprend bien pourquoi
la république en mars il ya cinq ans a
raflé la mise 21 millions d'euros par an
myriam c'est ce qu'on appelle un pactole
le jackpot ils ont décroché le gros lot
la timbale en 2017 au reprend le calcul
parce qu'on a tous compris tous ensemble
première partie de la dotation publique
9 millions d'euros pourquoi parce qu'en
2017 lrm a présenté 526 candidats tous
ceux qui parmi eux ont gagné minimum 1 %
des voix ont pu prétendre à l'aide
publique soit 9 millions d'euros
deuxième partie de la bourse sur ses 526
candidats 314 ont été élus députés ils
ont rapporté 12 millions d'euros vous me
suivez neuf +12 ça fait 21 millions
d'euros multiplié par cinq en soit le
blond thèbes en plus de 100 millions
d'euros pour le parti majoritaire et ça
et ça myriam ça fait rêver tous les
partis politiques surtout ceux qui ont
besoin de renflouer les caisses après la
présidentielle merci infiniment c'était
très clair j'espère que pour vous aussi
certains des spectateurs merci valérie
alors anne cheron bezina c'est vrai que
c'est finalement on comprend que
l'hélice la tis c'est l'élection rem
pour financer les partis politiques en
france en effet c'est l'élection reine
pour financer les partis politiques
alors c'est un système récent il faut le
dire parce que en 58 quand on a fondé
notre vème république au départ on
n'avait rien du tout aucune législation
concernant les partis politiques en tant
que tel et encore moins le financement
des partis et des campagnes donc c'est
les affaires on va dire qui ont conduit
à ce que des législations se succèdent
pour préciser un petit peu ces
conditions qu'on pourrait qualifier de
conditions de transparence finalement
qui se sont petit à petit imposé aux
formations politiques de comprendre
comment ça va se passer avant ce n'était
pas une subvention publique qui
permettent à trouver avoir affaire à des
crises personne
personne morale des crédits etc donc il
y avait vraiment on va dire une liberté
et une opacité aussi sur la manière dont
ces partis politiques étaient financés
avec une difficulté aussi à connaître
les sources et parfois on trouvait donc
dans ce système l'inde pour on pourrait
dire que les financements occultes était
pas nécessairement favorisés mais en
tout cas pouvait tout à fait exister et
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi les lois
transparence de 88 2 93 de 95 souvient
tous de 95 comme la grande loi après
voilà les affaires de la mairie de paris
le rpr jacques chirac donc c'est pas que
la loi 95 ce système la révision à date
de 88 pour l'essentiel 93 qui a encore
précisé 95 et vous le dites l'élection
reine notamment parce que on a cet
attachement particulier sous la vème
république à notre parlement au rôle des
députés et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
la seule élection où les partis
politiques ont vraiment un sens parce
que le sénat est très à part au niveau
de la manière de fonctionner des partis
politiques à plus de liberté il ya plus
de poids aussi aux des attachements
locaux parfois et pour la présidentielle
et bien c'est la logique gaullienne on
coupe complètement le cordon avec les
partis on veut que ce soit la rencontre
d'un homme et du peuple donc la vie des
partis elle se fait vraiment dans cette
élection législative dans les élections
locales on sait pas tout à fait la même
chose puisqu'on a quand même cette
tendance à la reconduction à on va dire
à presque un lien affectif avec l'élu
local qui n'est pas du tout le même que
le député donc c'est vraiment l'élection
où les partis ont plus de sens ont plus
de poids c'est très clair merci beaucoup
bonsoir a chuté mal des revenus sur ce
plateau jeudi des sénateurs socialistes
qui ne soutient pas la nuque baisse on
peut dire ça comme ça non mais que
mélenchon ces noms serveurs je sais pas
non c'est pas mon poids position moi je
suis pour nous de la gauche voilà avec
jean luc mélenchon telles que l'alliance
est une fête aujourd'hui mais en tout
cas je soutiens les candidats
socialistes qu'ils soient dans ou à la
cour
alors ok j'avais mal et a mal compris
manifestement su qu'au rond avec ma
famille politique les socialistes
d'accord plus de 6200 candidatures ont
été déposées pour ces élections
investi c'est un record avec ses règles
alors elles sont plus transparents on
m'a beaucoup parlé de la moralisation de
la vie politique ou à parler du ps qui
en difficulté financière mais quand on
voit tous ces candidats dur on se dit
que le système favorise
incontestablement les candidats on a vu
que partir est née ma liste déposés 401
candidature c'est une bonne chose on
veut pas dire à la fois il faut que les
français s'intéressent à l'ipo tiqué
quand il ya des candidats ça pose un
problème dire moi je suis considère qu'
on peut être candidat et dès lors qu'on
remplit les conditions et moi je suis
pour qu'il y ait des débats se servir
des candidats des débats et je crois que
c'est sain pour une démocratie dès lors
que les règles sont claires et je crois
qu'elles le sont même si moi sur le
fonctionnement et le financement des
politiques je fais des propositions j'en
ai fait au sénat et je crois qu'il faut
modifier des choses on va en parler plus
largement mais si on s'en tient au
financement des partis politiques par
les législatives on qu'on a vu cette
règle ça fait à peu près un 15,4 euros
par voie dans 50 circonscriptions quand
on a eu 50 cas contre lyon on a fait
plus importants et à cela on rajoute 37
mais un peu plus de 37000 euros par
députés
et par sénateurs c'est un c'est un bon
système
moi je crois qu'il faut vous faire des
modifications d'abord avant d'arriver
candidats il ya la question du
financement des campagnes électorales et
moi j'ai
non les poids de candidat il faut
financer sa campagne est donc à ce
moment là il ya ce qu'ils appellent ce
qu'on appelle la banque de démocratie
parce que les candidats ont de plus en
plus de mal à avoir des crédits donc il
ya une loi qui a été adoptée en 2017 par
la majorité sortante il y avait prévu
une banque de la démocratie moi j'ai
déposé un sens pas vraiment ça a été
refusé je pense que ça c'est le premier
sujet parce que ça c'est un sujet pour
les vite pour les candidats notamment à
la présidentielle qui ne parviennent pas
à obtenir des crédits bancaires et 7
aujourd'hui pour ouvrir même un compte
bancaire et après il ya d'avoir un
emprunt donc ça c'est des vrais sujets
on va en parler on a un sujet exprès
pour ça on voulait commencer sur les
législatives et le mode de financement
mais on y vient dans un tout petit
instant m expliquer nous en fait
multiplier les candidatures et faire de
bons scores c'est ça la recette magique
alors oui moi je pas si je serai en tant
qu'avocat je peux donner un éclairage là
dessus mais effectivement vu qu'il ya
des conséquences financières ça c'est un
site d quand des candidatures va dire
pas forcément moigne âge mais où nîmes
va forcément opportuniste mais en tout
cas derrière il peut y avoir aussi un
intérêt même s'ils savent très bien
qu'ils seront pas élus après ça pousse
ça peut être aussi pour diffuser ses
idées on n'est pas abrogée en fait pas
que la politique pour être élus parfois
c'est aussi pour diffuser ses idées lors
des campagnes donc c'est pas forcément
un négatif et comme vous le disiez je
veux dire enfin il n'y a pas assez de
candidats ou les candidats vont pas
quand il y en a plein c'est difficile de
s'en plaindre après si l'offre devient
illisible ou que c'est des candidatures
qui sont va dire pas sincère mais juste
pour des questions de financement ça
peut poser problème c'est intéressant on
se rend compte par exemple que le tout
vrillière a pu empocher deux cent seize
mille euros en 2020 sur cette base des
législatives des candidats aux
législatives on a dit que le parti
animalistes déposé enfin investi 421
candidats ya des partis j'ai vu ça
régionaliste alors évidemment quand on
est uniquement candidats en bretagne
savait pas forcément 50 candidats
investis donc on se regroupe on fait des
fédérations régionales pour pouvoir
atteindre donc il ya des stratégies un
peu de pas de contournement mais
d'adaptation par rapport aux règles on
les voit sur le terrain je suis après
c'est pas forcément illégitime puisque
des partis qui sont ancrées localement
ils sont un petit peu avoir par la règle
des 50 circonscriptions la question
derrière c'est à quoi sert l'argent si
sert à l'expression du suffrage à la
démocratie le pluralisme bande en soit
c'est un bon usage de l'argent public si
derrière ces des partis qui servent
juste à faire tourner à payer quelques
personnes et derrière c'est vraiment une
utilisation par frauduleuses mais en
tout cas un sincère de cet argent qui
est destiné à la vie politique là il ya
un problème après c'est une question de
seuil en soit le mécanisme fonctionne
pas trop mal mais après ou est ce qu'on
met le surplomb de baisse mais des
contentieux sur ces règles là où il est
c'est pour ça je parle des subventions
publiques elles sont versées à m ça va à
peu près c'est pas ce niveau là
quel niveau ça c'est plutôt en amont
lors des campagnes quand elle est mal
utilisée ou que l'argent là sur la
musique on va voir un sujet là dessus
mais ce qui m'intéresse avec vous
richard c'est de savoir si on fait mieux
que les autres d'une certaine façon
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins
européens comment les partis politiques
sont financés via ces élections alors ce
qui est sûr c'est que vu d'europe la
france le financement des partis
politiques est très réglementée donc il
y à un modèle français en tout cas en
apparence c'est évident notamment si on
regarde vers d'autres pays comme
l'italie la suisse la suède où il n'ya
pas de règle du tout c'est que les
financements sont essentiellement privés
par contre ça pose ou alors vous avez le
modèle inverse l'exemple allemand où
c'est l'état qui finance toute formation
politique qui dépasse 0,5 pour cent des
voix et qui peut donc bénéficier des
subsides même si cette formation
politique n'est pas représenté au
parlement on a quand même des règles qui
sont
médian très réglementé ou je dirais la
règle qui prévaut c'est la règle
prétendument de la transparence avec une
réglementation assez important monsieur
le sénateur pourra nous le dire sur les
dons privés qui sont extrêmement
réglementée par contre toute la question
qui est posée c'est la question du
contrôle bien évidemment parce que ce
n'est pas parce que des pays et ça je
crois qu'il faut le dire ce n'est pas
parce que des pays acceptent les dons
privés voire ne les encadrent pas que
ces dons privés ne sont pas contrôlés et
après au royaume uni par exemple il y a
eu des scandales parce qu'il y avait des
dons privés ou l'instance de contrôle a
révélé que les donateurs étaient des
lobbyistes patentés et les partis
politiques en ont pâti donc je crois que
ce qui est important d'avoir
la règle sur le financement ne règle pas
à elle seule le jeu politique il y à
d'autres éléments et dans des pays
parlementaire ne l'oublié pas dans des
pays où le parlement un réel point on
peut des fois se poser la question en
france on en parle souvent ici est bien
dans ces pays là la majorité
l'opposition utilise larmes du
financement comme un arm de duels et de
bataille en reprochant à l'un le
financement son financement etc donc je
crois qu'il faut pas tout insisté sur la
tipp de régulation la régulation sap est
aussi une régulation politique c'est à
dire la capacité de la majorité de
surveiller l'opposition et la capacité
de l'opposition bon de rappeler la
majorité qu'elle a reçu des dons pas
toujours très claires raciste est mal
avant de voir un sujet justement sur
comment ça se passe pour les candidats
en campagne là je parle de financement
des campagnes toujours sur cette
question du financement public une fois
élu est-ce que s'allier avec avec jean
luc mélenchon et les autres partis de
gauche ça a été aussi voilà une des
motivations sans langue de bois est ce
que est ce que essayer d'avoir un
maximum de députés ce que sans cette
alliance - de moins d'élus donc moins en
moins de moins d'argent mais la question
que vous posez je pense que personne n'a
la réponse parce que moi je peux vous
faire la démonstration de nous faire la
démonstration donc c'est mieux de
s'allier pour la plus de d'élus comme je
peux faire démonstration que ce n'est
pas vrai donc les deux choses n'y a pas
de dia pas de réalité donc ce qu'on peut
dire par contre c'est que aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que sur il y avait près la
dernière fois donc en 2007 y avait près
de 400 candidats socialistes donc qui
sont affiliés donc aux partis sionistes
dont qu'ils ont fait pour la plupart
d'entre eux 1 % oui et là il en avait
que 70 donc deux fait cette partie là
elle est moins importante
ensuite on peut estimer sa donc sur sa
mécaniquement donc on a moins après on
peut estimer que est ce que on aurait eu
plus ou moins députés et donc ça ça
c'est un débat mais sinon
j'aurais pu entendre votre argument si
on pensait qu'on n'aurait pas député et
bla on a beaucoup
a déposé plus de 50 candidats par
rapport à cette règle
ça permet de comprendre aussi les
chiffres derrière nous il n'y a pas de
pré vêtements ya perdrait un peu vous
garantir tu n'aurais plus ou moins ce
qui est clair c'est que le nom de
candidats est passé de près de quatre
cents à 70 ça pour coup c'est en réalité
d'anvers à salles
alors on va sur le terrain d'un point
quand même oui il y a une différence
assez notable entre le fait de recevoir
des dons par exemple privé mais ces dons
doivent être déclarés donc ce qui est
important au fond ce n'est pas toujours
la provenance des dons ce qui est
important c'est que les partis là
déclare de manière à ce que ça puisse
être vérifié et qu'on puisse savoir qui
a financé des mamans justement d'abord
restons sur les législatives en campagne
parce que là aussi il peut y avoir des
dons privés tout ça est plafonnée puis
après il ya la question
des de la présidentielle ça c'est
d'autres plafond et d'autres montants on
va essayer d'être très pédagogique ce
soir donc on va partir sur le terrain
pour voir comment justement des
candidats réussissent à financer leur
campagne c'est un reportage dans la
première circonscription d'eure-et-loir
signalé au ce
tract affiche permanence faire campagne
c'est aussi trouver des financements et
c'est un vrai casse tête le député
sortant candidat de la majorité
présidentielle le sait il n'en est pas à
sa première moi ce que j'ai fait c'est
un prêt personnel
pour être franc de 25000 euros qui me
permet de financer une grande partie des
dépenses de campagne et puis ensuite
j'ai de la famille et quelques amis qui
m'aident et qui donc font des dons
individuels que chacun et chaque
français a le droit de faire dans le
cadre d'une campagne avance la première
étape l'ouverture du compte de campagne
et ce n'est pas une évidence le candidat
du rassemblement national en sait
quelque chose oui effectivement la
difficulté c'est quand on va avoir une
banque et qu'il nous dise sans même les
deux le nom du parti donc c'est pas
particulièrement c'est pas du tout lié à
ça on le fait ça que pour nos clients on
ne fait pas ça chez nous alors qu'en
théorie chaque banque est obligée en
fait de le faire ou au moins de motiver
son refus concrètement on a fait
on avait plusieurs banques de ma ville
on a dû en faire quatre ou cinq je crois
une démarche auprès de la banque de
france plus tard le comte a enfin pu
être ouverts chaque candidat doit
ensuite jongler entre différents canaux
de financement et chez les républicains
l'heure est à l'austérité le candidat
préfère en sourire candidate aux
présidentielles vous l'avez pécresse n'a
pas réussi à se dépasser la barre des 5%
c'est la raison pour laquelle avait plus
qu'un contribuer au remboursement de la
dette la candidate valérie pécresse
c'est la manière dont nous a été
présenté les choses pour justifier le
passage d'un don en 2010 est un trait
les dons de particuliers eux sont
toujours d'actualité il année pendant la
campagne comme lors de cette réunion
publique alors je te nomme la suite le
mandataire financier en charge chaque
candidat on choisit un c'est lui qui
tient les cordons de la bourse donner
son récépissé et pour un déduire de ses
impôts 66% de son bon pied sent pas chez
le candidat de l'alliance de gauche la
nuque même schéma de financement pour
pouvoir faire face aux dépenses de la
campagne à prendre afin de materiel.net
faire un peu de boîtes aux lettres voilà
donc là on a les affiches les programmes
les programmes de huit pages là y en a
trente mille il y en a pour de l'argent
c'est à peu près 3000 euros pour les
distribuer pas de petites économies
mobilise les militants à une
distribution faite par la poste oui ça
trouve où se trouvent beaucoup d'argent
mais des tracts sur l'ensemble des
boîtes aux lettres pour toute la
circonscription ça représente entre 10
et 15 mille euros
récapitulons au total les candidats
prévoit un budget compris entre 15 et 50
mille euros des montants bien loin du
plafond 71000 602 euros dans cette
circonscription l'état rembourse jusqu'à
47 5% de celui ci soit 34 milles 11
euros mais pour cela il faut atteindre
5% des suffrages exprimés alors sur le
terrain la bataille est bel et bien
lancée
voilà pour l'ensemble des candidats en
lice dans cette circonscription anne
charlène bezina on se rend compte que
sur le terrain est bien c
les même son de cloche que certains
candidats à la présidentielle
difficultés d'accès au crédit les
banques ne jouent pas le jeu et là on se
demande si au fond les règles sont
suffisamment adapté est ce que l'état ne
doit pas supplée parfois à la difficulté
des candidats pour se financer il ya
deux logiques qui s'affrontent c'est à
dire de se dire il est démocratique de
considérer que la bataille politique n'a
pas à être aidée gérée et contrôlée par
l'état et que au fond un peu comme on
avait cette idéologie en 1789 de se dire
eh bien mon boulanger n'importe qui peut
devenir un élu de la république et donc
c'est à lui de savoir comment il
financera sa campagne il n'est pas
obligé d'être affiliés à un parti voilà
une logique un peu universaliste comme
ça qui avait prévalu à un moment qui
peut prévaloir dans certains petit état
même si c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt la deuxième logique qui prime qui
consiste à dire que quand on a pas
d'encadrement on a des candidats et des
partis qui peuvent fleurir est allé se
financer de manière occulte ou même sens
sans aucun contrôle et sans aucune
équité dans l'accès au financement et
donc aujourd'hui on est bien plus dans
cette deuxième logique de transparence
et finalement de logique d'égalité alors
qui a ses détracteurs aussi mais qui
consiste à dire que finalement il
faudrait que chacun des partis chacun
des candidats puissent avoir un accès
facilité aux financements au crédit
alors le système de la banque de la
démocratie justement qu'avait proposé
françois bayrou est celui-là c'est à
dire de considérer que cette somme cette
enveloppe finalement c'est de l'argent
public que nous donnons aux partis
politiques est bien que tout cet argent
soit finalement géré par un organisme
indépendant qui serait cette banque de
la démocratie et qui serait le seul
interlocuteur des partis et même des
personnes finalement qui veulent faire
de la vie politique donc c'est c'est
compliqué à mettre en place mais c'est
une logique qui qu'il faut adopter et
adapter réservé les nuls de souci majeur
c'est bien sûr est ce que l'argent
corrompt la démocratie est-ce que
l'afflux d'argent l'économiste julia
cagé a beaucoup écrit là-dessus est ce
que l'argent va corrompre les partis
politiques surtout s'il vient de
donateurs influent mais je tiens quand
même à lire la logique libérale se
défend aussi alors en france c'est
difficile à dire parce qu'en france on
estime que tout doit passer par l'état
tout doit être régulé par l'état
la logique libérale qui consiste à dire
les partis se finance comme ils veulent
y compris au niveau de donateurs privés
mais à condition qu'ils aient déclare
que ceux ci soient identifiés et qu'on
puisse donc les associés en disant tel
parti est financé par tel individu ou
tel film elle se défend ce si les
instances de contrôle jouent leur rôle
et ensuite c'est le jeu politique au
sein de l'assemblée est bien de faire en
sorte que celui qui a reçu de l'argent
par exemple d'un lobby puissant de la
chimie soit rappelé à l'ordre lorsqu à
l'assemblée nationale il défend des
abonnements favorable à ce lobby un mot
maître sur les contrôles qui existe dans
une campagne un candidat il doit déposer
un bilan de ses dépenses à la fin de la
campagne et là on a bien compris des
plafonds et tout ça est contrôlé par la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne donc quand ya un contentieux
donc en quel cas ça se ça se produit
déjà tout pour revenir un peu en arrière
en fait le comme l'accès au crédit ou au
compte en banque il est comme ça reste
plus limitée que ce concours en tout cas
c'est quand on lit les rapports la du
médiateur au crédit qui a été créée
récemment on voit que ça concerne une
minorité de candidats et c'est pas en
général des reculs de presse les tout
petits partis nous donnons pas de crédit
quand vous avez ce candidat qui explique
la banque n'a pas dit qu'en fait il est
tellement finalement il ya quatre ans
oui mais c'est ce qui me fait perdre
vous fait perdre quinze jours trois
semaines à grands pas c'est ça la
question en question avait plus du
timing en général la plupart ils
arrivent mais souvent ici mais trop tard
pourquoi parce qu'ils demandent qu à une
seule banque parce que mes dirigeants
savent même pas comment ça marche au
niveau local il faut trouver un
mandataire vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord a cité mon nom souvent fait ici
prennent tard et je vois j'ai les
dossiers moi je voi la halle et écran
vous allez répondre dans le cas des
contentieux et donc souvent il ya s'il
ya des difficultés aussi comprendre les
règles c'est très compliqué et parfois
sont pas formés après c'est bien aussi
c'est des amateurs on peut pas si vous
le recommande soit candidat et xperio
tout le monde soit expert donc souvent
il ya les difficultés là dessus mais en
fait les refus il ya des banques qui
refusent par principe tout il y en a qui
accepte après il y en a qui vérifie
aussi mais en fait quand on est un
particulier on va dans une banque et non
pas forcément de répondre dans leur en
fait et c'est la même chose pour les
candidats soient ils sont traités pareil
donc pas si on dirait mal et après c'est
pareil pour l'écrire c'est une question
simplement de taille mais il ya quand
même une défiance voire une méfiance au
moins des établissements bancaires quand
il s'agit de faire définition il ya
beaucoup de banques et souvent en tout
cas quand on regarde dans l'est les
rapports ou même un pratique souvent il
y arrive mais ça prend du temps mais
c'est mais il ya très très peu de refus
des correctifs est ce qu'il y avait
toujours des banques qui acceptent
qu'est ce que vous observez sur après
une première question globale par
rapport à ce que vous dites c est ce que
oui ou non la démocratie a un coût et
donc ça suppose un financement moi je
fais partie cette école-là je considère
que il ya effectivement un coup tout le
monde démocratique au méthane et je vais
aller la suite vous serez peut-être
moins d'accord donc ça c'est un coup et
donc c'est à dire comment il faudrait
d'argent parce que sinon votre banquier
en l'exemple dans votre exemple il a pas
que c'est un financement dont il n'a pas
candidat à la question qui nous est
posée c'est un il faut que tout le monde
puisse être candidat et donc pour être
candidat il ya des gens qu'on d'argent à
la base à ce que je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui en france les communes de
moins 9000 habitants vous n'avez pas de
compte de campagne donc si vous avez
beaucoup d'argent c'est plus simple
quand vous n'avez pas donc et parce que
s'il n'a pas de comptes campagne n'est
pas de remboursement donc bien que ce
qui laissait question l'assassinât s'est
produit dans un instant mais puisque
vous en parlez tous on va essayer d'y
voir plus clair sur des faits dont on
parlait c'est à dire l'idée que chacun
puisse avoir un accès ont subi qui n'a
pas les moyens l'idée aussi de le lire à
lys et moi je vous parle d'arrêter ce
cirque dollars était celui qui n'a donc
pas d'argent ni apax et oui moi je alors
que le plus dense poursuivi c'est que
cette victoire et au financement
justement aussi nous notre logique
française avait besoin d'interdire voire
même de déconseiller
d'être candidat c'est à dire pourquoi
historiquement il ya des indemnités
notamment pour les parlementaires c'est
pour justement permettre à tout individu
d'être candidat et ensuite pouvoir vivre
sans être sous double oppression à
l'époque historiquement oui je pouvoir
central c'est ça l'histoire en fait
c'est ça l'histoire
fonctionnement que c'est pas toujours
évident d'avoir accès à un crédit
bancaire et qu'il ya des disparités
quand même en fonction de voilà de son
de son patrimoine alors cette idée de la
banque de détail la démocratie que vous
avez largement abordée déjà on va
essayer d'y voir plus clair il ya des
pistes qui ont été évidemment mises sur
la table par un certain françois bayrou
comme
ce fut l'un des temps forts du débat
d'entre deux tours à plusieurs reprises
emmanuel macron accuse marine le pen de
dépendre du voire russe
obligé d'aller faire un prêt à
l'étranger c'est parce que aucune banque
française
n'a voulu m'accorder de près et vous
trouviez ça à l'époque tellement
scandaleux que vous avez fait voter une
loi sur la banque de la démocratie vous
ne l'avez jamais mis en oeuvre
marine le pen fait référence à cette
initiative de françois bayrou alors
ministre de la justice c'était en 2017
comme chacun d'entre vous le sait je
suis pas souvent un accord avec madame
le pen mais sur ce sujet j'ai moi aussi
rencontrer et je ne suis pas le seul de
très grandes difficultés venant de refus
de financements alors même que les
garanties existent et le garde des
sceaux annonce alors la création d'une
banque de la démocratie elle garantira
aux candidats la possibilité d'emprunter
pour financer leur campagne mais nicole
belloubet qui lui succède à la justice
fini par enterrer la mesure est question
notamment d'accès au crédit relève moins
d'une absence d'offre bancaire que qui
viendrait que viendrait combler la
banque de la démocratie que de questions
d'information ou de délai qui pourrait
être réglé par le médiateur du crédit
qui lui a été institué dans la loi
confiance 2017
en décembre dernier deux députés tirent
à nouveau la sonnette d alarme de plus
en plus de candidats se heurte au refus
des banques mais depuis les déboires de
valérie pécresse me yannick jadot à la
présidentielle sont venus rappeler que
toute campagne présente un risque pour
les banques mais aussi dans les
candidats
voilà racheter mal vous qui a milité
pour cette banque de la démocratie
qu'est ce que vous y mettez vous comme
contenu précisément et pour venir
combler quelques lacunes quelle
difficulté aujourd'hui concrètement
c'est la capacité pour chaque candidat
de pouvoir accéder s'il n'y arrive pas
vers une banque classique accéder à un
compte bancaire et un prêt parce que
c'est ça aujourd hui devrait la vraie
question donc il ya certaines garanties
à des refus et d'ailleurs même parfois
le banquier vous dis oui mais qu'est ce
que vous mettez en garantie de l'autre
côté donc y'a des gens qui n'ont pas des
moyens il n'y a pas des moindres la d40
y vas y c'est tout un dispositif global
et 13 aides dont monsieur bayrou ait
fait ça c'est un sujet important c'est
d'ailleurs une des conditions souvenez
vous de son ralliement à un modem à
l'époque
il fait noir là dessus épique depuis on
nous explique que ça ne savait rien moi
je constate encore une fois sur le
terrain ça sert je voulais dit donc moi
je suis pour qu'on entre sur cette brute
de la démocratie mais pareil sur le
financement des partis star mais tout ça
c'est un tout dire aujourd'hui je veux
juste un exemple aujourd'hui il à moitié
de français paient l'impôt sur le revenu
alors c'est une déduction suis de 66%
par contre ceux qui ne payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est la double
peine non seulement quand vous avez un
parti ça vous coûte 100 % il vous
financer ce qui en plus payer l'impôt
soit le cas oui il ya eu des vraies
questions de fond mais moi je sais pas
comment elle fonctionnerait cette banque
de la démocratie concrètement et oui ça
serait un organisme enfin bon ben ça
malheureusement on est on a affaire un
projet de loi qui n'a jamais été
appliqué et qui en plus ça a évolué
ensuite à la suite de différentes
discussions parlementaires donc mais
dans ce cas comment des 8 marie le pen
qui a dû aller vers des geeks et
étrangers pour financer sa campagne
qu'est ce qu'elle pourrait faire avec
une banque de la démocratie à s'en aller
voir les russes ou des tchèques alors
techniquement de toute façon la
législation a changé depuis c'est vrai
les ossements étrange on va dire que
s'ils ont des gros si beaucoup le trait
la banque d'où la démocratie c'était un
organisme indépendant qui était censé
alors je ne sais pas je ne sais plus si
c'est de manière obligatoire ou
facultatif je pense qu'au départ en fait
c'était tout le monde qui devait avoir
accès par cette banque et là je trouve
que c'est intéressant alors que si c'est
seulement ceux qui ont des problèmes il
ya des petites inégalités qui peuvent se
créer mais l'idée c'était en fait cet
organisme soit l'organisme central dont
l'attribution est de la bande de francs
par exemple voilà alors donc c'était
celui de la démocrate sld était adossée
à la caisse des dépôts et consignations
et qui était donc la corde organisme
indépendant complètement créé pour le
financement de la vie politique et qui
du coup elle et travailler en
cohabitation avec la commission
nationale de contrôle pour que les
deniers déjà on sache d'où ils
proviennent on sache qui peut y avoir
accès il y aurait finalement des
conditions qui auraient été fixée et
c'est sur ces conditions je crois
finalement que là le débat c'est un
petit peu on va dire cristallisé
malheureusement on n'a pas réussi à vous
dire mais ce qui est intéressant de
retenir dans cette proposition ian brown
privé y est revenu je crois l'année
dernière où l'année d'avant pour dire
que finalement c'était dans de la
commission des lois aujourd'hui garde
des sceaux concrètement en fait il ya
beaucoup de candidats sur le terrain qui
peuvent
alors voilà c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent
avoir des problèmes de financement et on
peut avoir des questions d'inéquité
d'inégalités et au moins ça permettrait
de régler le problème par l'universalité
réservé les moi ça voulait nous parler
des lobbies genou parler de lobby mais
surtout la banque de la démocratie
j'avoue que ça fait partie de ces
réformes dont je n'ai pas compris
qu'elle n'ait pas été prise durant ce
quinquennat parce que c'est une idée
claire que tout le monde comprend banque
de la démocratie à dos et vous l'avez
dit à la caisse des dépôts et
consignations qui finance des candidats
une sorte de guichet politique au fond
très franchement tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que ce serait une
bonne idée alors pourquoi ça n'a pas été
fait l'a peut-être le sénateur peut nous
en dire plus puisque vous avez
visiblement participer au débat est
déposée moi j'ai été élu juste après
parce que moi je donne donc la loi est
adoptée elle est depuis l été bloqués
alors vous souvenez quand suite monsieur
bayrou été débarqués ou démissionnés
enfin bon bref et depuis c'est que
successeurs n'ont jamais souhaité dont
on a déposé un moment on a écrit l autre
jour 10 cas pas de problème ils vont
dire voyez le médiateur est à peu près
donc circuler en avoir en fait c'est
assez fou c'est une loi adoptée aucun
décret n'a été appliquée nate et
présente donc un n'est pas appliquée
aujourd'hui dans les faits elle est dans
notre maison elle existe mais uniquement
dans le temps la loi alors ça c'est
quand même une question par ailleurs je
voulais juste dire pour les
téléspectateurs qui évidemment
s'inquiète parce que qui dit argent qui
influent sur la démocratie le
financement d'un parti n'est pas la
seule manière d'un flux et pour ce qu'il
voudrait pour les puissances d'argent
sur la démocratie il y a bien sûr les
lobbys les lobbys qui sont souvent dans
le couloir des assemblées ou en tout cas
pas loin qu'on retrouve et au niveau
européen il ya une initiative
intéressante depuis 2016 c'est le
registre des lobbys là aussi en matière
de financement savoir qui sont les
lobbys autorisée qui les parlementaires
rencontré quelle est l'influencé de ces
lobbys croyez moi c'est aussi important
que le financement pour les candidatures
conclure le point important c'est que ce
qui s'est passé à l'époque le conseil
d'état avait émis un avis plutôt réservé
en dix ans attendait on crée déjà le
médiateur du crédit pour les candidats
attendons de voir à quoi ça sert et
disait la banque cette banque la
démocratie là le projet n'est pas défini
donc moi je peux pas rendre d'avis donc
je pense que c'était une idée politique
mais ça n'a pas été mis en oeuvre
techniquement et quand on est rentré un
peu techniquement on s'est rendu compte
que ça posait aussi des questions
puisque la question est surtout de qui
va avoir accès parce que si je suis
personne je suis je dit filet moins
20000 euros j'ai aucune chance
d'atteindre le plafond bas une banque
privée il dirait évidemment non bon
voilà derrière c'est le contribuable qui
va payer donc là dessus il y avoir un
influent fallait donc il faut mettre des
fois des conditions et c'est tout mais
là avec une usine à gaz que dans la loi
l'année par contre c'est non il ya une
loi organique a dit vous êtes
réhabiliter donc là donc en vain -
façon on est l assemblée nationale n'ont
plus rien ou presque il a juste dit la
loi de modernisation et même refus il a
donc a priori on a déjà bien j'imaginais
l'état de la jambe est évident du
gouvernement elle avait été très clair
et coûté en tout cas c'était très
intéressant parce qu'on a pu un peu
voilà démêler un sujet assez technique
en même temps très concernant parce
qu'on a compris le contribuable est
directement impliqué dans tout cela en
plus que du citoyen bien évidemment
merci merci à vous merci infiniment va à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin
c'est une plume évidemment mais c'est
aussi une voix qui compte parmi ceux qui
analysent des bouleversements du monde
il vient de publier un essai un nouvel
essai chez perrin un autre monde l'ère
des dictateurs et c'est passionnant et
aussi à ses personnels sur à la fois le
métier de chroniqueur
internationale mais aussi la lente
agonie des démocraties libérales face à
l'irrésistible ascension de la chine
notamment après son jour de guerre en
ukraine on a beaucoup de questions à
poser au journaliste alain frachon comme
les skis ce sujet de marco polo
si on vous invite alain frachon c'est
pour commenter comme vous dites les
événements du vaste monde l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie en voilà un
événement qui a bouleversé surpris au
delà des frontières européennes
et pourtant dès juillet 2021
rappelez-vous vladimir poutine expliqué
que l'ukraine n'existait pas il annoncé
en quelque sorte la couleur le retour de
la guerre en europe c'est la leçon que
j'ai retiré le 50 ans de journalisme et
à couvrir notamment des régimes
autocratiques les autocrates font ce
qu'ils disent alain frachon vous êtes
l'un des éditorialistes les plus réputés
de la presse française dans le milieu on
vous appelle the voice pour votre voix
rauque si particulière bonjour là
bonjour l'école ancien correspondant à
jérusalem où washington voilà plusieurs
décennies que vous décrypter le monde
pour le journal le monde ancien
directeur du quotidien est aujourd'hui
chroniqueur vous avez compilés dans un
livre une centaine de vos chroniques des
sept dernières années vous dessinez un
autre monde l'ère des dictateurs car
d'après vous les occidentaux ont raté
leur entrée dans le 21e siècle nos
sommes tombés de haut ce que nous avons
prévu ne s'est pas réalisée au contraire
est classé manquera ci a vu monter qui
devait être le modèle le modèle
l'horizon politique générale à plus ou
moins à moyen terme ou à long terme ça
n'a pas marché au contraire c'est le
modèle autocratique qui a marché et qui
à monthey quand on a vu monter sans
arrêt le modèle autocratique en pleine
ascension avec d'un côté la chine en
passe de détrôner les etats-unis de leur
leadership
l'empiré du milieu se rêve première
puissance économique du monde de l'autre
la russie qui aspire de nouveau à la
grandeur en reconstituant l'ancien
empire us zijin vladimir poutine deux
dirigeants avec une ambition commune
détruire une influence de l'occident sur
les droits de l'homme et la démocratie
autrement dit créer un nouvel ordre
mondial et rejette pas tout non mais ils
disent cette manière qu e les
occidentaux d'infuser leur valeur et
d'essayer de nous les imposer comme
étant la morale vers laquelle tout le
monde doit tendre et le système
politique vers lequel tout le monde doit
tendre et bien nous n'en voulons pas
nous voulons que nos nos systèmes
politiques les autocraties ça soit aussi
les ultime que la démocratie bref alain
frachon avec vous nous voulons
comprendre ce monde disons chaotique
mais après tout on a t'il déjà été
autrement et pour finir cette question
le modèle démocratique occidental est il
mort à vous la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir à l'infraction bonsoir
invitation un autre monde chez perrin
recueil de vos chroniques publiée dans
journal le monde chaque jeudi au cours
de ces dernières cette d'année alors
justement l'ère des dictateurs c'est le
sous titre vous allez nous l'expliquer
parce que c'est un peu pour répondre à
la question qui vous est soumise par
marco pommier est ce qu'on est entré
dans dans un monde qui marque la fin du
modèle démocratique occidental
écoutez je crois qu on a appelé ça un
autre monde
pour une autre raison en fait je pense
que c'est un autre monde que celui que
nous avions imaginé à la fin de la
guerre froide lorsque l'union soviétique
s'est effondré de l'intérieur en fait
des occidentaux notamment les états unis
ils ont cru qu'ils avaient gagné la
guerre froide mais non ils n'ont pas
gagné la guerre froide c'est l'union
soviétique qu'il a perdue qui s'est
perdue elle même qui ces mines est elle
même temps ses résultats économiques et
sociaux était médiocre si l'on
lamentable donc voilà un peu ce qui
s'est passé que ce sont des dictateurs
les autocraties qui se sont développées
plus que nous occidentaux de grandes
démocraties qui se sont affaiblies parce
que vous êtes quand même très sévère on
vous dit bon ok il n'y a pas forcément
déclin mais que l'occident a raté son
entrée dans le 21e siècle guerre en irak
les crises financières bras exit assauts
du capitole montée inexorable des
populismes en europe elle est
catastrophique c'est votre mot l'entrée
dans le 21e siècle des grandes
démocraties n'est pas brillante mais je
ne parle pas de déclin pour autant je ne
crois pas que nous décline ion mais
forcément les rapports de force ont
changé donc ça s'est pas passé comme on
l'imaginait et au contraire du fait de
notre naïveté idéologique du fait aussi
de nos erreurs multiples elles bien les
autocraties en on monte elle le modèle
autocratique a pu séduire le nombre de
démocraties nous allende de régime
allant vers la démocratie diminue et
selon gérard nos erreurs à nous pays
occidentaux plus que nos valeurs des
démocraties qui sont remises en cause
écoutez là c'est une question très
difficile parce que nos valeurs c'est
quoi nos valeurs c'est la liberté mais
la liberté en a mis trois siècles pour
l'institutionnaliser dans nos
institutions qui sont celles de la
démocratie représentative
telle qu'on la pratique aujourd'hui à
paris à londres à rome et où ailleurs
dans le monde occidental
mais au fond ça c'est notre histoire et
je pense qu'il ya une spécificité de
notre histoire
autant je crois que nos valeurs sont
universelles comme le dit la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme qui y
prennent qui est la charte de l'onu qui
précède la charte de l'onu autant la
forme politique que nous lui avons donné
eh bien c'était un peu naïf d'imaginer
que beaucoup de pays allait se couler
comme ça dans un moule institutionnel
qui nous a fallu de trois siècles pour y
arriver et encore je vous écoute est
encore en débat encore faut-il faire
ceci ou cela
vous qui vous définissez dans le livre
comme un disciple ou même un enfant de
raymond aron elle a été portée au
vraiment au pinacle parce que on a
longtemps pensé que la liberté la
démocratie amènerait l'abord
l'enrichissement de la prospérité
économique et la paix ça c'est une
erreur c'est une erreur collective
oui et non en ce qui concerne l'europe
jusqu'à hier jusqu'à l'agression russe
contre l'ukraine c'était vrai vous et
moi on a connu ça on a vécu dans cet
univers la liberté politique égale
relative
richesse économique égale la paix c'est
quand même ce qui se passe en europe je
crois que le projet européen n'y est pas
pour rien même s'il n'explique pas tout
donc
voilà et en même temps domination trouve
quand même le contraire et ça ça vous
vous en parlait énormément dans le lycée
le plus passionnant je trouve il ya même
un essai supplémentaire un chapitre
supplémentaire par rapport aux
chroniques déjà publiés ce réveil de la
chine vous vous l'avez vu depuis
longtemps vous parlez des années 90
quand vous étiez d'ailleurs tourné vers
le moyen-orient vous disiez un intrus
qui cassait la vaisselle du train train
des aventures occidentale et
moyen-orientales masse puissante et
dévorante ébranlant notre froid notre
foi dans l'évident de vocation
universelle du modèle libéral démocrate
démocratique au fond c'est une guerre
idéologique que nous mène la chine oui
c'est une guerre idéologique culturelle
et biologique que la chine se posant
référent de la même manière que nous
nous sommes posée en référant nous les
démocraties libérales
la chine dit bah écoutez regardez nous
est un autre modèle c'est un autre
modèle nous n'ont pas la même
gouvernance que vous êtes un autre
modèle et ce que nous voulons c'est
façonner des institutions
internationales qui ne soit pas hostile
à notre modèle et ça c'est exactement ce
que vous expliquez vous dînez
idéologiques culturelles idéologiques
idéologico politique si vous voulez
alors saisi ping a imposé le culte de la
personnalité un peu comme mao tsé toung
qu'est-ce qui veut exactement dans cette
guerre des caisses qui veut remplacer
l'ordre occidental ou américains par
l'ordre chinois qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire la plupart des des sinologues ou
des spécialistes de la chine quand vous
posez cette question donnent leur
réponse qui est la suivante il ne veut
pas forcément
évidemment à l'évidence il ne veut pas
uniforme il unit for universaliser dans
univers à l'analyse et il ne va pas que
le monde entier ressemble au modèle
politique chinois
ce serait absurde mais il veut que l'
architecture
international l'organisation des
relations entre états l' architecture de
l'onu telle qu'elle est eh bien il veut
qu'elle soit interprété d'une manière
qui ne soit pas hostile à son régime
autrement dit il veut un monde il veut
une scène internationale qui soit sinon
en empathie mais du moins n'ont pas
hostile non hostile au système
autocratique tel qu'il le pratique à
héron voies rendant dans la menace faire
d' influence dans les institutions
onusiennes voilà la chine a arrive
absolument à parvenir à cet objectif
aurait semble-t-il comment vous
expliquer
certains alliés dans qu'on a du mal à
comprendre en tout cas la position de
l'inde la position par exemple de
l'arabie saoudite par rapport à la
russie on a l'impression que au fond
c'est quoi c'est un alignement une
neutralité ambigu roux clairement le
début d'une nouvelle alliance avec ces
pays la chine russie ça ressemble un peu
à un alignement tel qu'on a pu le
connaître au début des années 1950
pendant la guerre froide mais n'oubliez
pas que le lin alignement au fond aux
nations unies ça c'est toujours traduit
par des votes en faveur de l'union
soviétique et donc ça il faut pas
l'oublier cette perspective ça ressemble
à un alignement ça veut dire écoutez
vous êtes bien gentils vous les
occidentaux mais vos indignations
elles sont à géométrie variable et donc
ne nous obligez pas dans ce cas précis
celui nous obligez pas vous rangez
forcément derrière vous peut-être que
nous allons condamner mais allons
sûrement pas prendre des sanctions et
sont des pays souvent proches des
etats-unis comme le brésil comme le
mexique comme même singapour des pays
qui dépendent entièrement des états unis
pour la sécurité comme l'arabie saoudite
que vous mentionniez où l'état des
émirats arabes unis ne nous demandez pas
de prendre parti parce que nous nous
nous n'avons pas oublié 2003 lorsque
vous avez mené une guerre d'agression
contre l'irak autrement dit nous
considérons que vos indignations elles
sont à géométrie variable
c'est dans cette guerre que que nous
mène au fond la chine et la russie
leur facture car culturel c'est autre
chose idéologique ou culturelles suping
un allié de poids c'est évidemment
vladimir poutine on a vu les deux hommes
ensemble s'afficher aux jeux olympiques
de pékin jeudi vers juste avant
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine ces deux
là sont des alliés très solide en tout
cas de le dire parce que vous mentionnez
cette visite de vladimir poutine à pékin
au moment des jeux olympiques d'hiver en
février et après il va à pékin voir si
jean pinet regarde un peu la luge et le
ski s'endort d'ailleurs il a pas l'air
très en forme il s'endort mais après il
va appliquer et il signe à pékin un
document qui est un document que nous
n'avons pas ainsi lui alors c'est un
document long au moins dix pages comme
s'est traduit en anglais à peu près dix
pages et c'est un document qui décrit la
guerre culturelle ou idéologique que
vous mentionniez tout à l'heure c'est un
document qui dit voilà les idées
occidentales nous sont hostiles il nous
faut combattre les idées occidentales
pour construire une architecture
internationale qui ne soit plus sous
influence exclusive des occidentaux
c'est un texte dans lequel il invitait
dans le livre allait prendre
il faut toujours lire ce qu'écrivent les
automates les américains dans tout ça
disent très clairement depuis joe biden
qu'un affrontement et qu'il faut au fond
faire vivre le monde libre contre les
autocraties l'europe a intérêt à à venir
dans cette espèce de 2 2 face à face les
américains d'un côté avec ou sans
l'europe face à la chine et aux états
unis je crois je crois que en ce qui
concerne l'interprétation de la charte
de l'onu
l'architecturé de demain des relations
entre états de demain
l'europe est proche des états unis elles
divergent dans certains cas il faut
qu'elle sache diverger il faut qu'elles
puissent prendre une identité forte sur
la scène internationale s'est pas encore
totalement acquise mais on y va
doucement au moins dans le domaine
commercial et économique voire les
sanctions qui ont été prises contre la
russie mais si vous regardez et grosso
modo l'interprétation que pour les
américains la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme et celle que nous
en faisons nous aussi elles se
ressemblent
ça ne veut pas dire que nous thérèse
sont systématiquement convergent
notamment dans la relation avec la chine
parce que dans la relation avec la chine
je le dis je crois méfions nous du
conflit américano chinois n'oubliez pas
que tout l'été cela qu'on voit dehors
l'a1 est encore plus parce que elles
viennent d'une usine de shanghai
n'oubliez pas que les chinois ne se
gênent pas pour faire appel à wall
street pour constituer des fonds de
pension n'oubliez pas que derrière la
conflictuelle it et des deux discours de
sygic pictures by day il ya des intérêts
très fort et donc c'est là où l'europe
doit être suffisamment forte pour
défendre ses positions économiques dans
les relations avec la chine parce que
nous aurons forcément des relations
économiques avec la chine merci
infiniment n'aurait pu continuer des
heures c'est passionnant sunu dit au
fond que l'occident n'a pas dit son
dernier mot même si les débuts du 21e
siècle sont difficiles un autre monde
l'ère des dictateurs c'est aux éditions
perrin je vous propose de rester avec
moi pour écouter nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris peut-être qu'ils vont vous
faire réagir j'ai nommé elsa monde un
gamma pour son carnet de campagne des
législatives thibault enoch hier
aujourd'hui demain le sommet de la terre
et l'oeil sur le monde numérique de
delphine sabattier noah a franchi les
voies si on commençait avec vous ce soir
elle va carnet de campagne comme chaque
soir des législatives avec un gros plan
ce soir sur les circonscriptions des
français de l'étranger elles sont 11 et
elle vote ce week end exactement
exactement depuis le redécoupage
électoral de 2008 il ya effectivement 11
députés pour représenter les français
établis hors de france a représenté 1,4
million d'électeurs inscrits sur les
listes électorales le monde est donc
divisée en onze circonscriptions par
exemple on à l'amérique du nord
l'afrique du nord ou encore le benelux
pour belgique pays bas luxembourg ces
députés ne sont pas exactement élus en
même temps que les autres puisque les
français de l'étranger ils ont pu voter
jusqu'à mercredi sur internet vous me
direz c'est super c'est pratique sauf
que ça n'a pas du tout marché il ya eu
pearl buck plein de dysfonctionnements
avec des mots de passe qui ne sont
jamais arrivées alors ils peuvent
également voter par correspondance ou
par procuration et puis il ya des urnes
qui sont quand même mis à la disposition
dans les ambassades
c'est donc dimanche samedi pour les
français établis aux amériques et on
aura donc les résultats peut-être dès
dimanche soir au pire lundi matin alors
quels sont les circonscriptions qui va
falloir regarder de près on se souvient
qu'il ya cinq ans en 2012 en 2007 en
2012 en 2017 oui en 2007 j'avais écrit
2012 vous avez rémois je vois là je suis
déçu plinet en 2017 telle majorité
avaient fait le grand chelem et tout
raflé de ces circonscriptions exactement
10 sur 11 avaient été gagnées par la
majorité on va surveiller évidemment la
5e circonscription celle qui regroupe
l'espagne le portugal andorre et monaco
pourquoi bien parce que c'est celle où
se présentent manuel valls ancien
premier ministre ancien député élu alors
en essonne puis émigré à barcelone est
revenu réinvesti par la majorité mais
qui fait face à un dissident stéphane
vosges et à le député sortant match
intéressant également dans la 9e
circonscription celle de l'afrique de
l'ouest c'est l'ancien ministre pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elisabeth moreno qui se présente mais
elle fait face à plusieurs dissidence
dans son propre camp le référent
horizons de la circonscription se
présente est également le député sortant
exclu de la république en marche pour
avoir frappé un opposant politique et
vous nous parlez aussi ce soir dépôt tea
party oui j'en ai même pas trop être
appelé comme ça je vous en parlais dans
la première partie les l'animal est
évidemment vous avez vu peut-être ces
affiches regardez c'est celle du parti
animalistes voter pour un poussin vous
avez peut-être vu ses affiches à fleurir
ils ont présenté plus de 400 candidats
tout de même le plus connu d'entre eux
est bien c'est l'humoriste laurent
baffie alors valérie brochard et puis
pendant vos débats vous l'expliquer un
ça compte beaucoup pour le financement
des partis politiques font représenter
plus possible pour essayer d'avoir il ya
un petit peu d'argent il ya aussi c'est
un peu plus anecdotique mais le parti
pirate qui présenteraient de son
candidat alors lui petite particularité
vous ne verrez un ni le visage ni les
noms des candidats sur les affiches dans
le parti pirate il veut que vous votiez
pour ses idées pas pour les personnes
bon on va très bien merci voilà avertis
thibault hier aujourd'hui demain
chronique tout en archives sur ce soir
des sommets de la terre c'est ça
exactement on va parler d'écologie un
car elle soufflé ses bougies l'écologie
figure égouts ont fait pas moins de deux
anniversaires aujourd'hui les 30 ans du
sommet de rio en 1992 d'abord considéré
comme le premier acte ii quand de la
réponse mondiale au défi climatique et
puis les 50 ans de la conférence de
stockholm c'était en 1972 la toute
première conférence des nations unies
sur l'environnement cet anniversaire est
fêté dans la capitale suédoise depuis
hier avec un sommet organisé par l'onu
écouter le message d'anniversaire du
secrétaire général de l'organisation
antonio gutiérrez sortez nous de cet
enfer at il imploré les pays présents
l'enfer du réchauffement climatique
drôle d'anniversaire il faut dire qu'à
son âge 50 ans le combat climatique
devrait être en pleine maturité
malheureusement nous savons qu'il n'en
est rien l écologie est un enfant qui a
grandi très lentement alors revenons
justement sur ces prêts n'est pas
comment tout a commencé un plutôt bien
puisque en 1972 dont cannes et de la
conférence de stockholm la communauté
internationale avait presque un coup d'
avance dès ce sommet le constat
climatique est posée le communiqué final
reconnaissait que l'homme à transformer
l'environnement et qu'ils risquent de
commettre des dommages massifs et
irréversible le programme des nations
unies pour l'environnement est alors
créé tout ça dans une ambiance étrange
entre les représentants de l'onu d'un
côté et des hippies de l'autre regarder
stockholm vit depuis une semaine à
l'heure de l'environnement on a même
installé à la périphérie un gigantesque
camp de toile pour les i
dans le décor doré de l'opéra de
stockholm les délégués des 112 pays
participant à la première conférence des
nations unies sur l'environnement ont
été accueillis ce matin par le roi
gustave adolphe les travaux de la
conférence durant une dizaine de jours
les résolutions auxquelles ils
aboutiront n'auront pas d'effet
contraignant
vous l'avez entendu le programme n'est
pas contraignant c'est bien le problème
d'autant qu'il va falloir attendre vingt
années de plus pour qu'un nouveau sommet
de la terre pose réellement les
fondations d'une réponse climatique
c'est donc la conférence de rio en 1992
une centaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont présents un premier
traité est signé le début d'un long
processus selon les mots de françois
mitterrand à l'époque que cette
conférence
soit surtout le début d'un processus
destiné à se poursuivre et à s'amplifier
avançons dans la mise en oeuvre des
quatre grands chapitres d'un programme
pour le 21e siècle
l'agenda 21
alors l'agenda 21 premiers programmes
d'action concret international 1 contre
le réchauffement climatique problèmes
tout cela est toujours facultatif
résultat dix ans plus tard nous voici à
johannesburg on connaît ce discours
resté célèbre de jacques chirac la
maison brûle on est passé du coup
d'avancé au coup de retard regarder la
terre et l'humanité
sont en péril nous ne pourrons pas dire
que nous ne savions pas
prenons garde que le 21ème siècle ne
devienne pas pour les générations
futures
celui d'un créé mains de l'humanité
contre l'avis mise en garde qui sera
resté en grande partie veine pendant
toutes ces décennies vous l'aurez
compris on aura fixé des grands
objectifs sur les papiers monde en sera
resté à cela une écologie de papineau
qui hier aujourd'hui et demain alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer de ces
sommets ce qu'on va voir des avancées
concrètes dans ces grandes institutions
pour le climat alors on a comme
l'impression d'être entré dans une
nouvelle étape d'abord le cadre dans
lequel nous situons à présent qui est
celui de l'accord de paris en 2015 est
enfin contre nyon et puis le rythme des
sommets s'accélère à l'époque c'était on
s'était dit rendez vous dans dix ans
maintenant si on se revoit tous les six
mois et regarder le calendrier pour la
fin de l'année il est très chargé il y à
une coop comme tous les ans cette année
ce sera en egypte des décisions sont
prises presque chaque année dans ces
codes désormais et puis il ya des
sommets thématique après les sommets sur
les océans en début d'année une
conférence mondiale sur la biodiversité
va se tenir cet été en chine avant sont
en 2023 l'onu publiera pour la première
fois le bilan mondial de l'accord de
paris c'est le début d'un inventaire qui
va se poursuivre en 2024 avec ce qui
s'appelle le cadre de transparence ça
veut dire que chaque pays va désormais
devoir rendre compte de manière précise
de sa mise en oeuvre de ses engagements
climatiques en résumé nous voilà passé
d'une écologie de papier à une écologie
chiffré mais étant que derrière ces
chiffres maintenant il y est enfin une
réalité grâce à ça vous intéressant
parce que vous en parlez aussi la
question du climat est notamment de la
chine est ce qu'on peut faire confiance
au moins sur ce dossier là ad à des
avancées alors on est en retard donc on
enchaîne avec vous des fines vous nous
parler des cookies alors ce soir
l'oeil que vous avez sur le monde
numérique seulement 6% des français
refusent systématiquement d'être pisté
par des traceurs lorsqu'ils vont sur
inferno internet alors de quoi
parle-t-on précisément qu'est ce que
trace alors très vite les traceurs en
fait ce sont des petits fichiers qui
s'installe sur nos machines quand on va
visiter un site pour nous identifier
puis suivre tout ce qu'on fait je donne
un exemple vous avez décidé d'aller
visiter barcelone cet été vous fouillez
quelques sites de voyages et puis vous
passez à autre chose le soir vous
rentrez chez vous pour prendre des
nouvelles de vos amis vous vous
connecter sur facebook et là vous êtes
complètement encerclée par des
publicités vous proposant et bien des
cours d'espagnol ou encore des super
promos sur des valises à roulettes faut
pas accepter alors c'est à dire que peu
importe si ça vous intéresse ou pas mais
en tout cas en général soit ça vous
amuse un peu
en vous agaçant ça ça vous exaspère
totalement de pose question puisqu'on
peut se demander comment facebook avant
finalement de ces recherches qui sont
passés sur d'autres sites alors pour
nous donner plus de visibilité de
contrôle finalement sur la manière dont
sont utilisés nos données personnelles
sur internet l'europe édicter des règles
maintenant qui s'impose depuis quatre
ans au niveau européen c'est le rg et
parmi ces règles a l'obligation pour les
sites d'obtenir un consentement
explicite avant d'installer ces traceurs
justement sur nos ordinateurs et nos
smartphones ont depuis plus d'un an
s'est appliqué en france et donc la
question se pose pourquoi est-ce qu'on
continue d'accepter finalement à être
traqué lors qu'on peut refuser c'est
parce qu'on fait pas attention qu'en
france ça nous inquiète pas prof à
l'aider alors c'est vrai que on pourrait
imaginer qu'ils aient davantage de
progrès sur ces bannières de cookies de
consentement parce que aujourd'hui
parfois le bouton qui permet de
continuer sans accepter il est un peu
caché dans un coin il n'est pas aussi
évident que les autres que les autres
signalétique donc il ya des progrès à
faire il y avait beaucoup de plaintes en
2021 qui ont concerné les cookies 89 des
135 mise en demeure par la cnil ont
porté sur les cookies quand même 1
l'année dernière et l'une d'entre elles
concernaient facebook avec une amende de
60 millions d'euros parce qu'il ne
mettait pas une indication aussi simple
pour refuser que pour accepter un
legging ouais c'est ça le problème la
question est ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
ou pas est-ce que c'est grave ou pas
d'accepter les cookies moi ce que
j'entends c'est que les les internautes
s'inquiètent quand même d'être
surveillés l'étude dont vous faisiez
référence à que faisait référence aux
débuts publié par nordnet me dis quand
même que 79 % des internautes ont peur
d'être surveillée on se rappelle aussi
de la faire whatsapp quand ils ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient changer leurs
pratiques et autorisé le ciblage
publicitaire et bien y'a pleins
d'utilisateurs c'était comme un vent de
panique peut-être un peu exagéré mais tu
me dis oh la la il faut partir elle est
sur une messagerie plus sécurisé par
exemple signale donc on voit qu'il ya un
rejet quand même d'un numérique qui au
pack 2 un schéma unilatérale où
finalement on monétise nos données c'est
l'exploitation protéiforme des données
personnelles qui nous permet d'accéder à
ces services gratuits c'est un sujet de
liberté individuelle évidemment ce sujet
un sujet aussi deux choix de société
j'en avais parlé ici chez facebook
encore un moyen de cibler de manière
vraiment très très fine les utilisateurs
pour diffuser des publications politique
est influencée donc les électeurs et
puis c'est un problème de sécurité parce
que plus vous avez de données
personnelles qui circulent sur vous sur
internet permet vous encourez des
risques de violation dont je le répète
soyez vigilants tous qui captent des
données personnelles doit requérir notre
pleine et entière attention on voit ça
nous voilà avertis arrêter d'accepter
aveuglément vous acceptez pas tout ça si
j'ai prolongé long quelque chose me
disais que vous ne faisiez partie de ce
groupe en tout cas merci infiniment
merci alain frachon d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp un autre monde l'ère des
dictateurs c'est chez perrin très
intéressant aussi sur le regard que vous
portez de ce métier de chroniqueur cette
liberté chaque semaine à lire le jeudi
dans les colonnes du monde merci les
affranchis c'est le week end de la
pentecôte profitez bien tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire avec la z la
zone d'education documentaire de valérie
brochard
[Musique]